les conseillers départementaux ont voté
en séance plénière le budget primitif du
département pour cette année 2010 9,1
milliards 659 millions d'euros seront
consacrés aux actions menées par la
collectivité auprès des réunionnais nous
allons consacrer à gros budget à la
réunion dans tous les domaines collèges
routes éducation familles personnes
âgées jeunes tout ce que le département
faits et dans ce budget va vous avez
bien remarqué qu'il ya encore beaucoup
de dépenses en lien avec le rsa donc
c'est un sujet majeur mais c'était un
sujet de responsabilité et de solidarité
22 millions d'euros seront consacrés à
l'entretien des routes départementales
17 millions à l'amélioration de
l'habitat et 14 millions viendront
soutenir le développement du territoire
avec l'agriculture nous allons
poursuivre nos actions sur ses as ses
axes stratégiques que sont la reconquête
des terres en friche que ce soit
également le soutien aux produits
identitaires mais également apporter
notre contribution en tant que
contrepartie nationale aux fonds
européens aux feader pour pouvoir
continuer à moderniser les exploitations
agricoles
le département concentrera ses actions
sur l'élaboration d'un plan de lutte
contre la pauvreté la précarité auprès
des jeunes des familles et des seniors
des seniors qui seront également au
coeur d'un dispositif d'accompagnement
adaptées à la réunion le plan senior en
cette musique il y avait une réunion
sueur
comment envisager le bia vieillissement
notre créole et ben aujourd'hui on dit
c'est notre priorité
plus que les moyens qui on arrivera à
mettre de côté un afflux faudra aller
chercher aussi
dans le cadre de fonds social européen
l'uefa se va permettre à accompagner ben
le triplement futur de notre population
de grand monde malgré une diminution des
recettes fiscales
le département décide de ne pas
augmenter les impôts il maintient ses
dispositifs d aide aux personnes
fragiles comme le pass transport le pass
loisirs l'allocation personnalisée
d'autonomie et le shaq santé pour aider
à l' équilibre du budget la collectivité
abaisser ses frais de fonctionnement de
près de 10% cette année
[Musique]